З моменту "вбивства" і "воскресіння" російського журналіста
Аркадія Бабченка минув тиждень.
За цей час силовики зробили чимало заяв,
проте до слідства у цій справі лишається ще чимало запитань.
Так званий "розстрільний список", який з’явився
в ході розслідування справи Аркадія Бабченка,
цього тижня оприлюднили українські ЗМІ.
У ньому - імена 47 українських діячів та журналістів,
яких нібито мали вбити.
Втім, який зиск від цих убивств Кремлю, залишається неясним.
Адже серед названих осіб майже немає
жорстких критиків російської влади.
Зате є одразу п’ять українських письменників та чимало людей,
невідомих широкому загалу.
Викликає сумніви і походження цього списку.
Адже в СБУ спершу запевняли, що не передавали його пресі,
однак згодом визнали, що у ньому - ті самі прізвища,
що й у вилученому під час слідства документі.
Єдиний арештований, якому закидають
організацію злочину на замовлення російських спецслужб, -
український бізнесмен Борис Герман.
Утім, його версія подій, пов’язаних зі справою Бабченка,
кардинально відрізняється від озвученої силовиками.
Бізнесмен заявив, що є таємним агентом української контррозвідки,
і в історії з російським журналістом діяв саме в цій ролі.
Герман, зокрема, розповів, що виконував спецзавдання
з виявлення впливу російських фондів
на дестабілізацію ситуації в Україні та ймовірну зміну влади.
А також підтвердив, що його знайомий у "фонді Путіна"
передав йому список переважно росіян,
яких начебто хотів знищити Кремль.
Однак, за словами Германа, у цьому переліку було лише 30 осіб.
Спецоперація СБУ з імітації вбивства Аркадія Бабченка
підірвала довіру Заходу до українських спецслужб
та поставила нові виклики перед самими журналістами,
зокрема в питанні співпраці зі спецслужбами.
Медійники констатують брак інформації в цій справі,
мовляв, фактів та доказів реальної загрози журналістам досі немає.
А єдиним джерелом такої інформації є правоохоронці -
ті самі, які офіційно підтверджували загибель Бабченка.